oh my sorry i'm not moving right now because i have to take
pictures of this i was not expecting the proto-dokies to
show up i not expecting that i was like why do i have
another package why do i okay i need to also buy fabric glue
because um uh because like the the the final draft one it's
just a sample so it's like bit it's like a bit dirty and
also because you know it's like the lap that's the sample so
they don't like do like actual they don't like what's the
word they don't polish it as much as the like like the one
that's for for sale because it's a sample so i need to buy
fabric glue because uh um i need to buy five fabric glue
because uh the piece one like a bit of the hair is sort of
coming off so i need to i need to like fix that real quick
uh because usually samples are meant to be destroyed later.
So because they want to make sure that everything, they want
to make sure that like everything is good.
So they don't want to put in like the highest quality for
like during the sampling stage.
And then when it's fully finished, then they like put more
care to it because they didn't know this was the finalized
version yet.
But yeah, no, the first proto-joke, they were like, are you
sure you, are you sure do you want it?
like close-ups of the very, of the very first proto-doki.
And it was like, there was like markers on it, like the face
was drawn on.
And then it's like, there was black markings on the hair
where they trace the hair to cut it and everything.
And I was just like, yes, I wanted, like, are you sure?
And I was like, yes, I am sure.
So, Sonia, let me buy, let me order a fabric glue real quick
guys um all right well just that's all I'm going to order
I'm just going to order one fabric glue I'll take a picture
and I'll show you guys it's so fucking dumb it's so I would
buy water too just because like I don't want to like waste
just you know you want to I don't want just buy one thing if
I'm ordering Uber Eats in this a got it so hot in my room
right now I've I'm so sorry for being late.
I was trying to do errands and stuff because it is Monday,
so everything is open.
I won't get all that done before I pack for my vacation.
And then I was stuck at the bank for an hour.
Yay.
I love being stuck in the bank for an hour.
I will grab this.
And then if you don't have that.
All right, I'm taking a picture of this.
Like, yeah.
All right.
I was not expecting it.
I was like, what the fuck?
what is that okay also good news they made two extras so
that means i can auction two proto-dokies for it so two
lucky dragons for charity by the way this would be for
charity will be able to get a proto-dokie i'm checking just
double checking there's no reflections or me is that a
reflection I can't tell I don't think so oh just to be safe
I'm gonna blur it out just to be safe all right let me blur
this out just in case if it's a reflection or not but I will
be auctioning them out for charity in the future I don't
know when whenever I do a charity is event
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm blurring the reflections right now, guys.
Give me a sec.
I don't even remember which is the blur thing.
Is it this?
Oh, yeah, it's this.
Doing it live.
I love doing stuff live.
Okay, that should be good.
And then I'll do that here just in case.
there you go if it seems wonky is because i was trying to
make sure there was no reflections
all right there is this too
yeah i only have like one phone for all of this and that's
why uh i'm not moving on the screen right now i'm trying to
fix proto-dokie
for the fine lines the quality is so good it is so good for
a sample um it was just unfortunate that the uh a part of
the uh like it's not it didn't come off but it's like it's
like half half off so i have to like get a fabric glue and
glue it back together it's just like a small part of the
hair but there's like black markers all over it though not
all over it but there's like uh a bit of the hair has like
black markers on it because they're they're like tracing the
pattern and stuff to make sure like um to make sure
everything is like correct uh but but do not worry because
this is the sample guys the only the sample is like this uh
because they're trying to like make sure like they're trying
to figure out exactly what they want what we want so uh when
the finalize when like the you know the force the the the
mini jokies that are for like that will be sent to you guys
our distributor is gonna quality check all of them to make
sure they're all like the same quality and stuff like all
the high quality we might if we might sell like if we find
like c grade or b grades uh we'll sell them for cheaper
because I don't want to waste it.
Yeah, it's the prototype, not the final product.
So I just want to get caught.
I want to ease your worries in case.
But that's just basically how prototyping is done.
Usually the prototype version is a little bit lower quality
than the final version.
Because what if you don't like it?
And then they're like, oh, we have this.
like if you don't like it then like what can they do with
this type deal so they want to make sure like everything is
good to go before they before they invest in that the actual
fabrics
um okay i have the picture now i'm sending it to myself all
right let me double check i can double check everything okay
um all right there you go I got it.
Yeah, it's like concept art, basically.
All right.
All right, I'll show you guys.
It's so fucking...
I was like, there's like another...
I was like, another package.
Why do I have another package?
I was just waiting for one package.
All right.
I'm like...
a shower after this i'm so sweaty from doing all my errands
and stuff and trying to get back home in time well obviously
i did not i didn't succeed in the getting home back in time
part um i did not succeed in that all right let
me double check i'm i better be safe than sorry all right
I'm just double checking everything don't worry we'll be
with our manhara soon guys I'm the the substitute I'm just a
substitute I'm just filling in for a bit before we get our
real manhara all right here it is look at it's so stupid
it's like a fucking naked gingerbread like the face is drawn
on by the way guys with marker it's the triplets it's
literally drawn on with marker by the way the eyes let me
show you guys it's crazy I was like what the fuck yeah
they're so beautiful wait
What?
They're the same picture.
It's the same picture.
It really is.
I found my OG.
It's the same picture.
It's so stupid.
I love her face.
The fact that it's like, it's like drawn on with a mark or
two.
It's not even like...
embroidered or anything it's literally they got a marker and
drew this onto so each doll has its own unique eyes what
picture oh my god wait actually let me show them where let
me show them where like each face you can tell which one's
the very first one sort of yeah you can tell holy she's so
The very first proto-Doki is so messed up.
It's so messed up.
You can tell which one's the first one.
Wait, all right, give me a sec.
I'm not going to be moving yet.
All right, thank you for the 20 gifted chips.
Thank you.
All right, I took them out of the package.
I should have just done that in the beginning.
All right, oh my God, they're like holding hands.
it's so cute yeah you can tell which one is the oldest who
was the oldest sibling you can tell who is the oldest
sibling in the group
no don't keep their mint condition we need we needed to take
them out of the rappers anyway all
right Oh my god, this is a big-ass picture.
All right, here it is.
Guys, can you tell which one was the first proto-doki?
Can you tell?
Mother, mother, what has thou created me?
Which one was the first proto-doki?
Gee, I wonder who it is.
God left me the fourth, the far right one.
But yeah, it's just...
I'm super excited, though, to...
Let me put them away.
I'm super excited to bring the finalized sample with me on
my vacation.
because I've always wanted to take, like, lots of photos
with these, like, mini-dokies and stuff.
Like, I'm going for, like, my official mini-dokies
everywhere.
So I'm super excited.
Oh, my, I was so worried because, like, it wasn't supposed
to, it was supposed to arrive today.
And, but then, like, the delivery guy was like, oh, we
weren't able to reach you.
So we're going to come deliver tomorrow.
And I was just like, oh, no, I wanted it today.
I don't want to wait tomorrow.
And then I asked my manager.
I was like, can you call it delivery?
Because I didn't want to talk on the phone.
So I didn't want to deal with customer service.
So I was like, manager, can you talk to the delivery people
and tell them to deliver it today?
Because I don't want to wait tomorrow.
he was like fine so yay my manager made the adult calls for
me yippee uh he made the he he made the adult calls and
helped me talk to adults to help me solve adult problems
like am i beautiful mother sorry thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you it's because i had to go outside
and i had to deal with a bank so i wanted to save my energy
for bank stuff
also yes i had to do two wire transfers because the bank was
open today because you know it's monday and um and there was
literally one bank teller at the desk uh one like it wasn't
even closing close it wasn't even closing hours yet like i
still had like two hours till closing um and literally it
was just one person luckily i was the next one in the line
when i got there and then i fucking hate my bank i it took
me like an hour to do two wire transfers because the thing
is um they need a supervisor to sign off on the bank the
wire Canada.
You're like, why don't you do it online?
That is not the Canadian way.
We are so bureaucratic and so fucking, uh, uh, so many
checks and balances and so much bureaucracy and like trying
to make it as hard as possible for you to get anything done
and you have to do everything in person.
Um, we do not do things online for some fucking reason.
We're like 200 years behind.
it's truly the Canadian way and you better be doing this at
your designated branch if you go to the wrong branch say
goodbye to your wire transfer anyway anyway um I uh I wanted
I had the the thing the thing that made it super long
because it was two wire transfers not like I'm doing like 10
or 5 of them um they need a supervisor to sign off on the
wire transfer but the supervisor was apparently on a very
heated phone call argument with some someone on the other
end because someone on the other end also apparently really
fucking hates the hate the bank and she was like um sir i am
not yelling at you you are the one that's like i was like
listening in and they're like um you are the one that's
yelling at me i'm talking in a very calm voice right now
like that's like i was just listening to this argument from
the supervisor and then the bank
I can't do anything until she signs it off so um you will
just have to wait and we're just standing here awkwardly
listening to the supervisor having a very calm exchange as
per her words uh and then so so I have to wait for that and
then she signs off uh she signs off one of the when it you
know when when the argument was done she finally signed off
my uh finally signed off wire transfers and then by the way
while all this is going the line behind me was getting
longer and longer while we were all waiting the lot sister
was only one one thing teller that was working the line
behind me was getting longer and longer and longer and um
and then when we're working on
messed up once.
So she needed to wait.
So every time, like, like I said, so we had to wait for the
supervisor twice, one to approve the transfer, like, and
then second time to like, we had to re-approve it because I
was like, oh, there's a typo here.
I didn't want to lose all that money because of the fucking
typo.
So we had to wait.
So it took an entire hour.
It took a fucking entire hour to get my bank shit done.
Um, G, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I can watch stream at home because I've got a cold.
I just threw up every spring.
Oh, no.
I hope you get better.
It sucks.
I don't get sick.
Fucking sucks.
So I hope you do get better soon, G.
Thank you.
Gus, thank you.
Did you put the name in the goblet of fire?
The big magic ass comedy.
I need a super chat.
Thank you.
Um, what else?
Oh, yeah.
And then I really wanted to be like, um, you know get like
uh uh this is a woman's thing but if you guys didn't know
women grow hair on their face but it's hard to tell because
we have to upkeep that shit um also because like i'm asian
so it doesn't grow as bad but like um the one thing i hate
is that i have my my eyebrows are like grow really really
fast and it's like thick so like i hate that uh because it's
really thick And so, like, I haven't got my eyebrows done in
a long time.
And I was like, after the bank, I was like, oh, hey, I think
I still have, like, oh, wait, no, before the bank, I was
like, okay, I'm going to do this before I head to the bank.
And then it was closed.
It was closed.
I'm so sad.
It was closed on Monday because I was like, I'm going to go
on vacation.
I didn't want to look like a fucking slob.
like I was like you know because like you know since I've
always been stuck at home working I don't have to worry
about that I get to wear pajamas I get to wear pajamas all
day and then like order out don't have to show myself to the
world and I was thinking oh I gotta actually like not be a
slav and actually be like presentable outside so I was like
I'm gonna I should just um I should like actually like make
myself look nice when I'm on vacation like you know you know
like you so I could like feel good about myself and then it
was closed on Monday so that means I have to go out not even
oh my god it's closed on Tuesday too that means I have to go
out again I was saving my going out days for my vacation.
I can't believe it.
I was trying to get everything done in one day so I could
save up my going out days on my vacation day.
Like touching grass day should be on my vacation day.
Not for my at home days.
Like manual at a timing.
so yeah I was just like it's okay but luckily we are playing
today we are playing what the fuck is this game called men
herarium so finally we can fix someone that's even I might
not be able to fix my life but I can fix her alright
um char thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hey
dokey i just want to let you know that finally got your skin
in apex and to celebrate i unsealed apex off my computer yay
thank you for the super chat thank you bro you're missing
out they have a gondom collab now to figure out pay for the
skins but like i will say the gondom skins are pretty sick
apparently um for one of the emotes i like playing around
with this little bear scarf by the way i was at the market
because, you know, I was trying to get everything done on
one day, so I don't have to go out again until my vacation.
You know, I gotta save my energy for that.
Like, what if I get sick before my vacation, guys?
So, and they were selling these really cute bear-shaped
bottles, and they had, like, knitted hats and scarves, and
it's so fucking cute.
Anyway, I'm just, like, playing with the scarves.
I'm, like, I'm just, like, visioning with the scarves right
now.
think of the super chat oh yeah but yeah the Altair has like
apparently a unique email where he just pulls out a fucking
Gundam like he just pulls it out he just pulls out a fucking
box of Gundam uh Noctil's think of the super chat thank you
thank you women have facial hair yeah sure next thing you'll
say is that women poop or something dumb like that think of
the super chat thank you thank you um let's see uh Ella
think of the super chat thank you thank you pause you're a
woman I thought you were a bro all this time.
The best bro is a woman.
But, um, wait, wait, where is it?
Jacob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Joki.
It's my birthday today.
Can you get happy birthday from my first and favorite Oshi?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday dear Keiko, happy
birthday to you, yeah, happy birthday, yeah!
Terminator, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, um, but yeah,
someone's like, why didn't you just use a tweezer?
that because I don't fucking know how to do it like like the
reason why I go to a professional is that they can make it
symmetrical oh I would like keep plucking it and I'll be
like oh that's too much and I'll pluck the other side and
I'll be like oh that's too much and I'll pluck the other
side and then I'll be like no eyebrows left oops oops no
eyebrows also I do the threading ones the threading ones is
easier I like um for all you women out there and men you
want to learn uh women facts um i do the threading ones
where like they use like a piece of like use like string to
like do the eyebrows because it's a lot faster and less
painful uh oddly thank you for a 10 gift of chips thank you
thank you mr broken bond thank you in the super chat thank
you thank you if you're such a bro lend me 20 you mean you
lend me 20 thank you for the super chat
Gordon, they give us super chat, super chat, thank you,
thank you.
I like how you bought Gag Trinkets for Sounders Effects
instead of using a proper soundboard.
Because it's funnier.
Because it's like, the sound quality is lower, so it's
funnier.
The faraway trombone.
See, it's funnier.
It's more authentic.
You know, it's just...
The sad trombone 20 miles away.
like the sad sad drum vote okay where was that um uh but
yeah it's unfortunate i gotta wait till wednesday to go out
again i used up my go out you know there's like sick days
those are my instead of sick days as a content creator
instead of sick days i have going out days touching grass
days i don't have many of those days guys i have to waste
another touching grass day yeah right um uh so but yeah
anyway we're gonna be playing manhara riem how did i find
this game um i don't know i just didn't know what to play
today uh i didn't know what to play yesterday but yesterday
played a horsey game on twitch but today i was like i don't
know what to play and i was like just browsing through steam
and i was like what the fuck is that and what and i saw that
one person one person wish listed this game on my friends
list i won't say who uh but i did reveal it on twitch i was
like what the fuck is this But apparently it's a roguelike
game where you're rolling dice against Manhara.
For those who don't know what Manhara is, it's basically a
crazy girl, a crazy girlfriend.
And, like, and you're playing with your blood.
And I don't know why, but I have this really strong urge to
fix her.
I think I can fix her, guys.
I really think so.
Gio thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hey
doky my birthday is just your vacation can you happy
birthday in advance also eyebrows on fleek yes girl thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you of course happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear
geo happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday so yes i am
very curious how this game is gonna be um anyway let me
check when this is gonna arrive real quick because they are
gonna call me to get to my door so all right all right let's
play i can fix her guys we can fix her together.
It's a group effort.
Surely all of us can work together to fix her.
If I can't fix myself, maybe I can fix her.
Inappropriate text for streams and video uploads.
How inappropriate.
It can't be that inappropriate.
Green.
Green blood?
Oh my god.
What's wrong with me?
Green blood.
blood all right guys let's test her luck she seems oh my
gosh she's wearing the manhara outfit too uh she just needs
like uh was it she just had it just is this pigtails oh my
god she has the pigtail outfit all right yeah shrek blood
she's purpose that was called g-okay yeah yeah all right i
don't know sound guys here
what let's go gambling say no I was
worried I'd mess up the mess it's in dosage who are you
handcuffs baby you don't need to handcuff me baby girl oh
shit Alright, let's go!
We're so in!
Turn it up!
I'm sorry, the sudden abduction and confinement must have...
I thought you would take a look at me unless I did something
like this.
Am I right?
Oh my god, why are they...
Oh, is that the medicine she drugged me with?
Hearing all of this must be a bother, right?
I prepared a very thrilling game, but only for you.
For me?
Pick your favorite one.
Oh, she has some gifts for me.
Oh yeah, I turned it up, by the way.
Amulets grant special effects like score multipliers and
activate automatic when condition is met.
Bonus effect attached to your selected deck.
Okay, cool.
So I get battery, change the current role to any number Over
500 HP.
Damn, that's a strong-ass burger.
I did not know burgers could recover my blood.
Uh...
Alright.
Is that your limit?
Wait, what does she do?
What am I gonna do with you?
Oh, you want more?
Alright.
I turned it up a little bit more.
She made me food, guys!
Oh my, she's the best girlfriend ever.
She made me food, guys.
Alright.
Yes.
Look at that.
I'll turn down the...
Child, we get back to the game.
If you're a stronger combination of mine, the victory is...
Oh, that's...
easy it's seven roll that dice oh my god i did it when both
are all single the one with the higher total roll wins all
right if the hands are the same the outcome is decided by a
total value of the dice so oh because there's double oh so
you have to have double dice to win but if you don't have
double is whoever has the higher numbers.
Okay, that's easy.
Even if you don't like your roll, you can press the reroll
button to try again.
I'm already won.
Yeah, I already won.
When your dice match and reach the target score to clear the
game, you lose HP equal to your bet each turn.
Oh, wait, is she giving her my blood?
Is she giving me blood too?
Is she also linked to the blood?
And view the combination.
I've been playing a lot of gambling stuff, guys.
I don't know what...
Is that bad?
I just realized...
I just realized this league has been a lot of gambling.
I swear I don't have a problem.
I swear.
I can stop this anytime I want.
Let it ride!
Alright, I mean, I won, right?
I hope we have the same blood type.
That would be pretty awkward.
I did it!
The entry fee for this game is your blood.
I'll draw blood equal to the bet amount.
gambling, gambit, gambit, thank you, super chat, thank you,
thank you.
I hope we share the same blood type.
Does that be pretty awkward?
I just want you to feel lots of excitement.
It's okay, it's okay, baby girl.
I can survive.
Seven days?
Seven minutes.
That's all it takes.
Whatever I say
All right Jesus three fives How do I win that?
Okay Between this and Poker Knight Dokey has been gambling a
lot lately Nobody showed to Also we went to the horse race
too The horse derby yesterday
Surely I'll get three sixes, right?
Okay, it's okay.
I can keep re-rolling.
Okay, we were so close.
Wait, 130.
I mean...
Oh, no.
Change the current rule to any number.
I'm gonna do it.
Bam!
That's right!
You're gonna do whatever I say.
Oh my god, maybe she'll let me sleep on her.
Maybe she'll let me put my head on her lap, guys.
Do you think I could ask her for that if I win, guys?
Oh my god!
Larza, thank you for the 15 gifted chips!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Oh my god, thank you.
Thank you so much for the support.
So boring.
Yeah, I want some more excitement.
Oh, she called me a Zaka.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, she's spicy.
I like that.
The Menhara network.
Oh, my gosh.
She's spicy, guys.
whoa she's perfect that's not how you survive a monera guys
we're not here to survive we're here to enjoy the experience
you're actually rated rated in six categories the better you
do the more coins you get experiment and find out each coin
based on your earn coins based on your result use them in
the shop we're here for a good time not for a long time you
we know what we're getting into we we know exactly what
we're getting into
after i drew in dice matches your dragon drop to change the
order restores hp immediately upon purchase i don't need to
purchase that only evans at turn start if hp bent 100
customized wait how much do i have i i okay i think this is
strong the phone is fucking strong as hell delete amulet
coins are required to delete select effects okay on use add
16 and choose one of three elements it's time to gamba on
victory hp 200 when real 55 percent chance for every one
coin owned on victory recover five hp i didn't even get the
cat cat looks good all right multi what multi up what is
that oh is it customized roll or blue chair i think we're
fine here it's fine i don't want to spend i want to save i'm
save money wait oh wait this doesn't this doesn't cost
anything oh yeah we should finish that
let's call it a day just get some rest too oh yeah i gotta
recharge my blood
oh baby i will never run away i will i promise i'll fix you
Wait.
No, no, I won't betray you!
She seems so nice.
She's so protective of me.
She's so caring.
Guys, just want to make sure I'm taking care of.
Do you still feel like you're dreaming?
Also, sound guy is it better now?
Yeah, I can fix it.
Special rule I like how normal she is Yeah What Double the
I'll double the bet Oh yeah, I'll double the bet
Three fives Okay No, no, those guys There is no way There is
no fucking way Like, is she using weighted dies?
Oh, oh, sorry, I was not looking at it correctly.
Okay, now it's never mind.
I was looking at this.
I didn't realize it's different from the top.
I'm actually, that's all right.
I'm fine, guys.
I still win.
There you go.
I was looking at the die.
I was looking at gamers don't look up.
remember that holy shit she's drinking my blood that's hot
technically that means that means i made it the home run
guys my blood is inside there i did it guys i made it i
that's very unhygienic if you think about it that's a home
run Oh,
okay, yeah, now I lose
Change the current I should do that, right?
Change the current role to any number Oh, wait
Okay, if I can get a six
Take the head No, it's okay I can win this It's okay Okay
It's okay, I want it to lose.
She was so thirsty.
Girl.
She was so thirsty, guys.
Oh, yeah, I won.
Yay!
Excellent game choice today, Doki.
I've been taking with a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was just hydrating her.
Making sure.
You're making sure that she's hydrated.
Oh, it's easy.
I
got buy one.
Yay!
You put up for the bed.
Okay, those are rules.
Can't be held.
Sayonara.
Oh, my stuff is here.
Yes, I survived day two.
What do you think of me?
I think you're pretty cute.
I would never, what?
I would never lie to you!
Huh?
Like when you suck my blood.
Oh no!
Never!
Lolly, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
But, like, there's your face, your hair, your fashion,
your...
Your bobs, your butt.
It is all so cute!
Oh, nice.
$14.
Got the guts.
Yeah.
You can choose one of three rolls.
Okay, we gotta get the blood up.
Okay, we gotta get another blood up.
We are not doing so well.
On victory, bet 150.
If a roll of six appears, multiple...
Oh my god, it is like Balotra.
Double your bet.
Okay, maybe not that.
I want to buy this.
Let's grab a five.
Attach it to any fate.
Oh my god, wait, this is like Balotra.
I can have more fives.
Let's get rid of the ones.
Okay.
We want to get rid of the ones, right?
This is better than Palo Alto.
I get a girlfriend.
And all she wants to do is suck me.
Like, not the way I thought it was going to happen.
But hey.
A win's a win A win Whoa That's the plus Yo yeah Clover Pit
from Manera Which one do we get rid of The ones are I feel
like ones right Or maybe twos Twos are worth nothing to me
Wait what I'll get rid of the twos
So it's good that I saved this I do another one too Oh shit
Okay let's get the six then And then we'll change this to
six Uh Are you sure you want to continue Yeah let's make
sure we're fully
Alright let's go
I can't believe I can only stay here for seven days Chikada,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She thinks I'm cool, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Ta-da, ma-da-da-na.
Doki is just making sure she's keeping hydrated and getting
that blood flowing because she is staying up for Doki and
she deserves it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why'd you swap six with a six?
Because I'm not thinking straight.
She's sucking me off right now.
how can I think in these conditions?
How can I...
Fair.
All right.
Judging the same, add one extra dice.
The third dice becomes invisible.
Look at- I get a special pack!
Wait, that sucks!
Wait, wait a minute!
Wait a minute!
Maybe I shouldn't have pressed that.
Whoa, okay, wait, this is pretty bad.
Wait, I might have fucked up!
Okay.
I'm not thinking again!
Wait, maybe this will be a winner.
No, wait, I got the multiplier.
Did I win?
I can't.
I did not win.
Okay, my turn.
I couldn't tell.
Oh, should I have to reroll?
I couldn't.
I can't.
How can you how can we think with her in front of me?
Well, I can win this Okay, I think I think we should let her
oh I'm double no No
Okay, this is winnable.
This is winnable.
I just need I just oh my god Bam That's a win right here I
got my multiplier, too.
Am I dying or am I sandbagging?
Holy fuck.
All right.
I just need a six and then I'll change the day.
Maybe her.
Wait.
This is winnable.
I can pick.
I could change the die on this to be a five, and then I
outrank her.
There's no way.
Okay, there's no way.
Are you fucking kidding?
Why?
She had a triple five.
Oh my god.
Oh, no, we have to reroll this.
Oh The house always wins There's no way hers is hers is
bigger
I don't know if I'm gonna make it.
I don't know if I'm gonna make it guys
Oh, no, this is bad.
This is this is so bad Oh, no, I have one die left.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
This has to be good.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
We're okay.
We're not okay, but we're okay.
The house now owns your house.
How is she getting all the big ticket rolls?
Oh, my God.
There's no way she out wins this.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
I don't.
Guys, I don't think I have 2000 blood.
Maybe I can survive this.
I don't think I have.
Can I drink one of your sodas please?
I really, really need some extra blood.
Okay I healed 30 HP.
I healed she drank 250 by a healed 30 HP
Please baby girl.
Oh my god Please baby girl Spare me please let me drink a
little bit more water just just let me know
From where you're sad this must be like an 18 karat run of
bad luck truth is the game was really from the start.
Patrick arrested.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Edding dead.
But at least I went out my way.
I like.
But it was the best three days of my life.
All right.
That's- Oh, I get other stuff.
Now, someone's left hand on victory each roll.
Wait, what's that?
Someone's right hand.
Change number of rolls to any current number.
For each overkill, multiplier, X3.
I don't know which one would be good.
Per odd roll.
I feel like each even roll, maybe?
Looks like I get a burger.
Yeah, who is that someone?
Am I not your first?
Who was he?
I'm not jealous or anything.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
I don't need that.
Yeah, that's actually my hand from the last one.
Overkill?
A ridiculously high score?
Don't let you off the bet this time.
Oh, she's not gonna do the suck.
Yeah, I worked so hard.
You're having a great time.
I'd love to do this again.
How about next week, Tuesday?
I should have enough blood by then.
She likes me!
All right, let's see, I have $20?
I gotta get that gotcha Final defense system Alright That's
I mean, they're not wrong For pair combinations Rerol one
dice To a random
Don't even know It's the best one We gotta be safe guys We
gotta be safe If HP is full plus 300 bet win ties same okay
we uh oh wait it's an item same ring combos on you is 20 if
a roll of five appears multiplier i'm gonna choose one more
rare amulet when hp is recovered gain one stack every four
times roll effects activate every four times roll okay i
feel like please i need the hp that's the that's the thing
that fucked me up last time
You need to get some rest and prepare for tomorrow.
Yeah, I gotta regenerate my blood.
I'll never run away.
I'm here for life.
I'm set for life.
She trusts me!
I knew she was the one.
Oh my god.
I knew it.
What the fuck am I watching?
It's like the...
It's like...
It's Biloutro, but even better.
Because there's a hot anime girlfriend.
A special rule?
What is it this time?
Bet multiplier always 1.5.
The smooth effects of win scores reduces by 200.
Um...
yeah fine i don't care about that surely i won't be rolling
a bunch of even numbers now right
gimmick activated it yippee
all right
oh my god that's a high ticket oh what Oh, she had a double!
Alright, I can roll again.
Are you serious?
Oh, it's okay, I can get another double.
Oh, no.
Okay, okay.
It's okay.
It's just a hundred.
It's just a hundred blood.
Hundred blood won't hurt nobody.
Guys, I can't use my item.
I gotta save it for, like, for like, you know, a tense
situation.
no i didn't because like she had a double double triumphs
over
okay i might have to swap a number yeah all
right there we go are you serious okay there is fine it's
fine i still win regardless i just wouldn't meant more
points broken bond thank you the super chat thank you thank
you why is jokey mod coming to replace the for dragons leave
a super chat thank you thank you
all right that's good that there's no double don't worry
i'll get a double
uh don't worry the next role will be a double
so we're just straight up playing port what do you mean it's
gambling it's she has her clothes on What do you mean?
If anything, this is so PG.
I'm just gambling.
I'm just gotchaing my blood like a normal person.
Oh shit, I'm gonna lose this.
That's okay, I have a hamburger.
I'm gonna give her a super chat, thank you, thank you.
This is a perfectly normal game.
Are you serious?
Do I not have any numbers?
This is my last reroll.
Are you fucking kidding?
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
Sorry,
it's...
It's gambling with no real money.
Instead, I'm just gambling my blood.
And the best part is, like, I can regenerate blood whenever
I want.
You know?
I can't regenerate money, but I can regenerate blood.
I can always get more blood, guys.
All right, I survived.
all right a handmade meal from you darling
yeah yeah oh another one wait who's that i don't have two
left ends wait wait a minute who's the other left hand
Affinity relation
All right, I gotta get the roll.
Okay, I gotta get my blood back I'll grab the roll Oh the
double I'm gonna grab the six And then I'll change the flat
five for Why don't I change it for Yeah, I'll change the six
for that And then a utility knife i hope it's used for
cutting packages but every four times roll active effects
activate bet plus 200 use 10 add 10 20 percent of your
current target score customize roll okay we're gonna grab
the pizza in case in case something happens to me in case
something happens to me 45 coins on.
Why would I want a minus 2?
Do I not want more multipliers?
I'm going to grab the bank.
I know I don't have $5 yet right now, but I'm playing the
long game chat.
Because I'm so confident I'll survive another day.
Yeah, but consider it.
It's her panties.
Some sacrifices have to be made, guys.
Oh, hi, y'all.
Oh, I know.
I'm special.
She thinks I'm special, guys.
Okay, now I know why.
This was on her wish list.
Yeah, this is her type of game.
Look, I saw roguelike.
And I like you guys know I like roguelikes guys you guys
know that Okay scores below a thousand are invalid.
Okay, okay.
We're not gonna do I know it was very tempting last time But
like The siren won't tempt me this time Don't worry I won't
listen to the siren call Okay, maybe another reroll.
I learned my lesson.
All right, I'll just lose.
I'll take this.
I'll take it.
Yeah.
I just...
Just this one time.
What the fuck is this?
How did she keep getting all these fives and sixes?
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll do one more re-roll.
Are you kidding me?
There's no way.
Someone check her die.
I'm pretty sure like half her dice is like five or six.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
That's one six, but that's not... At least it's not three
sixes.
I can't fuck that.
time sheet are you okay wait okay come on oh thank god all
right here you go all right it's okay it's winnable it's
winnable guys it's winnable i have a pizza and a burger we
can we can live through this yep drinking your blood for
it's natural people used to drink blood back then We drink
animal blood.
What's wrong with a little human blood?
Alright, win.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that is...
Oh, my God.
Okay, that multiplier was actually pretty good.
That's true.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I can take that.
Unless... Unless...
Oh my god!
The gods want me to save for another day.
There we go.
Oh my god, it's raining blood.
Oh, baby, a triple.
Oh my god, I've exceeded her expectations.
I'm the best she's ever had I'm like blood type A or some
shit A for more vitamins Um Somewhere you want to go Of
course What?
That is so romantic
But I don't need a thing I just you think for me I'll just
do whatever you want to do
yeah blood type s because you're special that's me alright
$22 she's one of six rolls oh on victory total roll is even
gain four coins okay I like the the free re-rolls was nice
though i'm gonna grab that and then we gotta refill the
blood real quick um i need to keep five coins so i'll choose
the roll pack oh that's three though i have the three rolls
thing for every five coins owned but like
Do I save money, or do I...
I know it stacks for every five, but then I can have cool
dice.
Oh, this one's five.
Envelope prints coins.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, I'll buy the envelope.
I might be able to get more stuff later.
No, I think Doki's blood type A can say how much.
Next, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got this, because then I can...
He can give me coins.
Oh, wait.
Yes, I am.
It's just like 30.
I was just like...
I'm like...
Day 3 cleared, huh?
Oh my god, the best she ever had.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Come on, stay with me.
Or...
Kawaii Shini-sama.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, she's falling for me, guys.
I might be her forever blood pack.
I think we could go steady.
Your heart will be racing.
All right, give me a select time.
Add one extra die.
Pro, yeah, give that, wait.
I had extra die.
What, is extra die bad?
How could that be bad?
More die, more chances for me.
Oh, but also for her.
Okay.
All right, we should.
We just need a triple.
Oh, shit.
Oh, look at that multiplier.
I told you.
We're printing money right now.
Oh, my God.
We're left-hand gaming.
Thank you.
Thank you, past blood piggy.
Forgive me that.
Give me that left-hand.
All right.
My turn.
Little blood bank came in clutch.
Dookie can't stop winning.
Oh, what?
No!
I said win!
Oh, no!
The fucking protection!
The final defense system messed me up!
I saw win!
I'm...
I'm a fool.
Okay, I can reroll.
She didn't roll four, five, six without using any items.
How is that?
Wait, what's four, five, six?
What does that mean?
Is that good?
Oh, it's tripped.
It's an actual combo.
It's a win.
Who cares?
You're right.
A win's a win.
It means you rolled four, five, six.
Oh, yeah, I know.
There's no winning for that one.
Wait, unless...
Oh, wait, wait.
Yes!
Triple!
Oh, baby, a triple!
That's right.
that holy shit that's so much that has a lot of points it is
like that gambling game what is it called the the oh sorry
they're all again it's like the the slots machine one this
remind it reminds me of the slots machine one oh then but
balatro yeah i need more i need two fives or two six oh come
on wait unless no no don't you Yes!
Oh, yeah, it's like Clover Pit.
It reminds me of that.
There we go.
We need more...
Like, we need more...
Amulets.
We have room for one more amulet.
I don't know.
I was, like, just scrolling through my Steam, like, trending
page, and I saw it there.
And I was like, oh, that's a decent amount of reviews.
I walk into you.
I'm scambling.
An amulet.
Yay!
The worst you can see is no.
Or maybe kill you.
But like, the worst you can see is no, guys.
Oh my god.
What did I get?
What is that?
Wait, what the fuck was that?
Okay.
Choose a roll.
I'm grabbing another six.
All sixes.
It's like my seven run.
If any odd number is rolled, multiply plus max HP,
customized roll.
Oh my god, I can just make it all sixes.
I can actually just make it all sixes.
Oh my god, it's just all six.
Oops.
Oh my god, and I can buy another six.
I can buy another one.
I can just keep buying sixes.
I feel like my Amulet's really good already.
Oh, replace the three.
Oh, you're right.
Wait, but then this is odd, though.
I need odd.
Or I could get rid of the giant turnip.
Maybe I can...
Wait, bet plus means you die faster.
I don't have it.
Oh.
Okay, but if I get an odd number...
Wait, can I sell it?
How do I sell it?
Do you want it?
Do you want my bug?
dude oh i delete it
okay there you go bye i hope she didn't see me burning that
okay i can buy another one per roach i start lay an egg into
an empty amulet i want to transform into the selected amulet
if you have a required amulets multiplier plus when hp gain
one stack for every on victory recovery
okay which one yeah we don't worry she doesn't know which
one should i get should i get the coin purse i don't it says
on a tame transforms into the selected amulet but i don't
know what that means i don't know about that it's like a
it's a keychain right guys it's just a keychain It's just
a...
See, it has a...
It's just a...
It's like those iPhone sockets, you know?
Like those old iPhone...
Those...
You know when you use...
It's like those really old iPhone sockets where you put like
a little figure on top of the socket where you plug in your
headphone slots.
You know, you know those.
Oh wait, I can get another left tab, you're right.
Another left-hand.
Alright.
Yeah, it's a plug for phones.
It's a phone plug, guys.
It's a dust plug, guys.
Don't you remember dust plugs?
Alright, here we go.
Oh yeah, those sixes are gonna go crazy.
It's literally, we're back to our seven runs.
It's like sevens, but with sixes.
So I want to spend more time with you.
No, I'm having so much fun, I swear.
Alright.
What are the rules this time?
Target scored?
Oh fuck, they're all fucking terrible.
I feel like the odd number, right?
because like target score is double i don't know if we can
make it half hp
oh you're right i can eat a burger you're right yeah i have
a burger it should be five oh she didn't think i would take
that don't worry i have so many sixes i have sixes for days
what
What?
But I have sixes for days.
That doesn't make sense.
It's okay.
I can reroll.
It's okay I can still reroll again.
It's okay, I can re-roll again.
I have the re-roll one, so...
Oh my god, it's just that easy.
It really is.
I actually had three re-rolls, guys.
This is insane.
I...
Holy fuck!
It gave me three re-rolls in a roll.
triple baby saved oh shit all right my turn it came in
clutch I knew the cats got my back oh oh are you fucking
kidding me I was gonna win that my final defense my ass okay
there you go all right come on six six Okay, I'll take this
I can take this I have a burger I can take this I have a
burger.
I'll eat it now I should eat it now
Oh my god, I forgot about my hot I forgot about my hot
sauce.
I've had it for so long that I forgot it existed I forgot I
had that Okay, I can still I can still keep rolling Yes
Yes!
Oh my god Thank god Thank god for the final defense Alright
I got the bank bonus
She just needs protein guys She has iron deficiency She's
trying to get more iron I'm just helping a girl out, you
know?
Or you want her to die or something?
She literally has iron deficiency right now, and I'm giving
her my iron.
Oh my god.
The sixes are coming in clutch.
You're gonna have iron.
Don't worry, I can take the pills.
She doesn't like pills.
I'm just trying to help her.
She doesn't like swallowing pills, guys.
What's wrong all of a sudden?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
I just wanted to ask about your date.
It's not true.
No, of course not.
No, girl.
Here, you want to suck more my blood here.
Here, suck.
Here, I can't.
Here, use my blood.
Just keep sucking.
All right.
Choose an amulet.
Total roll ballot 18 chance to...
I don't like any of these.
Laser harp.
I feel like what I have is already really good.
Isn't it?
Yeah, what I have is already crazy good.
Guys, I can fix her.
I can fix her, guys.
What's this?
all right oh there's no sixes but there's a five oh shit why
did i pick a five wait go back go back i fucked up i fucked
up i forgot i don't need a five i i was like oh shit i'll
grab another burger
Fuck it.
Yep, I could've got an even number.
I think it's fine.
I don't need more items.
Yeah, I was gonna say the four, five, six.
I was like, oh, shit, I forgot about that.
Yeah, I'm gonna save.
I need a save for the multi.
The bank multiplier.
Oh?
What part?
I said a lot of things.
I'm a streamer.
You're that gamble fumbles all over.
That's my O.
She's solid.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
What?
Today?
But I thought we were in love.
This post?
Not happening.
I'm fighting back.
Maybe she'll think it's cool.
Maybe she'll be like, ooh, so alpha.
Oh!
I don't think she thought it was cool.
The one time I stand up for myself, the one time I can't do
anything right.
I don't understand.
The one time I was like, don't worry, I'll show her.
I'll show her that I'm alpha.
.
I thought I could fix her.
Can I not?
No, there's no way.
What?
Okay, there's no way they're going to seal my two left
hands.
Oh my god.
No, the bottom is too good.
Oh, this is bad.
Okay, which one did it steal?
Which one did it steal?
Oh, it steals my items.
Okay, that's fine.
I still have my burger.
It is possible.
Holy shit.
Wait, I'm going to do another read.
roll i believe yes i told you i told you i believe okay the
left hand buff oh my god my hands it's raining hands it's
okay i didn't need my pizza i have my burger oh okay okay
it's okay i got my sixes Oh, let's fucking go.
Is it in our six?
What?
Let's see, I can reroll.
Oh, and there we go.
Look at that.
Baby, a triple.
Oh, my God.
And then the hands for days, too.
The hands for days.
The sixth strat.
It always works, guys.
I learned that in Clover Pit.
Oh shit, okay.
Should have traded your sixes!
Look at that.
I'm all hands.
Actually, I was very, very hydrated.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I think my girlfriend might be a little Manhara.
Oh,
it's not your fault.
No, it's okay.
It's not your fault.
It was me.
I triggered you.
You know, I should have been...
We can play again.
Wait.
I won't die.
I'll say that.
Maybe that's the right answer.
Oh my god, did I finally do it?
Did I finally say one right answer?
Oh my god, I did it!
I fixed it all!
I might have fucked up seven times!
But on the eighth try, she forgave me.
Of course!
Of course you deserve happiness!
Of course you do!
Everyone makes mistakes!
You made me more than one, but like, you know, we're all
human!
see guys i'm fixing her oh my god is that another six is
that oh my god is that another six i see all right we'll
change we'll change that one another six dice effects
becomes positive oh yeah we gotta buy this
It's okay.
No, we'll be fine.
Wait, do I have to re-forge it?
Re-forge which one?
Is it this one?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, let's re-forge that.
Is that...
That's okay now, right?
Yeah, it should be fine now.
I'm okay.
Refresh something.
refresh.
Maybe we'll grab another six.
Oh my god, is that Mario?
Oh nice.
Oh my god, is that another six I see?
Is that, oh my god, is that another six?
Let's go.
Oh my god, I could grab this and then get another six.
Can I delete an item?
No, I can't.
Oh, like, let it ride.
Let's refresh.
Oh, my God.
Let's go.
Wait.
Okay.
Was it four or five?
Six is the...
Okay, four.
Okay, I don't have a...
Okay, we have four or five.
So we could change this to a six, technically.
Because we just need four, five, six, right?
So then we got four.
We got five.
You can change this and then get another six.
This heals plus 43 and has a multi.
Oh, wait.
I could replace a one as well.
You're right.
I'll just replace a one.
Replace this one.
Alright.
You know what?
Wait.
If you roll four, five, six combo.
win ties same rank okay wait maybe we can get another six
though no i'm i'm playing too much i'm i need to keep my
bank multiplier
yeah i gotta keep my multiplier she's happy again look at
that see
It's hard.
It's okay.
I know you were just grumpy.
You were just a little grouchy because you didn't get your
nappy time.
It's okay, girl.
I understand.
Of course I'll forgive you.
She just didn't drink enough of my blood.
Look, she can't live without me.
It's totally fine.
gosh she's so sweet guys you guys like my new girlfriend
she's so good to me
that's all it takes i'm just a simple bird i'm just i'm just
a simple bird
She'll do anything I ask!
Oh my god!
She might let me hold her hand!
Oh my god, if I win, I can finally hold her hand!
Alright, what is this?
if it's reversed.
Items cannot use re-roll.
Oh, fuck.
I'm gonna do a re-roll.
I hope...
I feel like...
Items, but what if I need the burger, guys?
I think I'm fine about the re-roll because, like, I'm
worried that I might need to use the food more.
I have more benefits with the food.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's so in love.
All sixes.
Okay.
It could change into a six right now.
Yes!
Oh my god, she's so happy that I won too.
She's so supportive, guys.
Guys, she's so supportive of me.
She's so supportive too.
all right it's okay 245 okay i might have fucked up about
that it's okay i still have
all right roll oh my god is that more sixes
oh oh
Oh It's okay.
I have a hamburger guys.
I have a hamburger.
It's okay.
I have a hamburger Three threes Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I have I can get three sixes Come on.
Come on.
Come on Are you?
Okay.
It's okay.
I have I have so much food Trust the process guys trust the
process.
I have so much food Okay, I'm just gonna eat a pizza real
quick
Okay, it's okay.
We got a little hungry We got that pizza.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Double two Choose?
Come on.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Thank God.
And we get a heal too.
Oh my gosh, she can't live without me.
Oh my god, this relationship is perfect.
She's so self, she's so dependent on me.
We have like a, what are those relationship calls where
like, you can't live with the other person because they're
so co- it's a co-dependent.
Oh my god, we're so co-dependent with each other.
It's so romantic.
It's so romantic
Doki, that's bad Guys, I think not having Reworld might have
been really bad
Okay, it's okay, I have another pizza.
Okay, I can eat another pizza.
You know what?
I'll just eat all pizza.
Oops, all pizza.
Where are my sixes?
Okay, there's one.
There's one.
Oh my god, I got four, five, six.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that actually works out.
Okay.
2000?
Fuck.
Okay.
Yeah, that one five is messing me up right now.
Forty odds.
My die is literally all sixes.
What are the fucking odds?
Wait, can I?
Oh my god.
It's okay, I still have the bird...
Two sixes!
It's okay, maybe I'll get three sixes.
It's okay.
I have full HP, guys.
I have full HP there's still hope there's still hope it's
still winnable I don't understand on day six when she was
super scary it was just six six six six come on oh thank God
thank God it's okay This means we can be with her longer.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait, he's spitting.
He's spitting some truth right now.
All right.
Let him cook, guys.
Let him cook.
Thank God.
Oh my God.
Finally!
Wait, I think that's it.
I think that pushes me over.
Oh my god, that does.
I made it.
Overkill!
Yeah, so you wanna...
You wanna be with me longer, right?
It's reward time!
I can finally hold her hand!
Yeah?
It's my heart.
Yay!
Wait?
We did it!
We fixed it!
I did it!
We did it guys!
Oh my god, we got it!
What happened?
What happened to me?
10-5 snooze too You know what?
Nice.
What a...
And I died happy.
Worth it.
Later, the Monero reportedly said The emancipated corpse
drained of everything somehow looked satisfied.
I will overcome my grief and live on strong, she said.
Went to Bahala.
That was fun.
Congratulations on clearing story mode.
Each time you clear, you can challenge yourself with higher
difficulty levels.
Rogue-like mode has now been locked.
If story mode felt too easy for you, be sure to give it a
try.
I'm too scared to click on the gallery on stream.
Let me click on...
Okay.
Alright, luckily, luckily it's not too bad.
It just tells you how to win the other one.
Satan, thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I love a happy...
That was such a happy ending, guys.
I died doing what I loved.
Yeah, there's other endings.
Please let me go disappear.
while having lost her interest.
Demonstrate your resolve to stay with her and win a serious
match.
I guess it's like the hardest difficulty.
So there's six different endings.
Oh my god.
I barely unlocked.
Bro, the left hand amlet actually was so good.
It came in so clutch for me.
Oh my, there's so many gimmicks too.
I'm doing what you love.
Yes.
That was fun.
fun i was actually i love like like the the different types
of gimmicks and mechanics for it is really fun i said thank
you the super chat thank you thank you joki couldn't see all
those red flags even after they were made with her very own
blood when all i see is red everything is a red flag and
that means it's good that means it's normal it uh but yeah
um i always like roguelike um so it was interesting to check
it out the red flags are sometimes yeah the red flags are
just green flags stained in blood so are they really red all
the red flags just look like flags um but i had a great time
oh wait wait i think i'm gonna wait let me grab this fabric
glue real quick i shall do that after stream um i mean i
love this game i love the roguelike of i love playing this
game because of the roguelikes guys yes the roguelikes and
the opportunity to fix her to fix this really nice girl
anyway guys i'm actually a bit tired because of all the
errands going outside but um this is a little shorter stream
um than usual but i hope you guys had fun watching everyone
um this was a very interesting game i it was a random game
that i found on steam and i was like oh it has a lot of
reviews and i felt like you know what maybe it'll be fun and
it was it was pretty interesting it was it was very
interesting next thank you super chat thank you thank you
this stream was an all-time for clips thank you so much
thank you super chat thank you thank you scarlet welcome to
tomato farm welcome welcome um but i hope you guys all
enjoyed today's stream um this is a little short uh it is a
little shorter than usual but um i do have a lot of stuff to
do today um and also i've i did a lot of stuff this morning
too i had to go outside so i'm gonna go rest up now um there
won't be a stream tomorrow packing for my vacation tomorrow.
But when my vacation starts, I will be doing at least one
stream during my vacation.
One gorilla stream during my vacation.
So keep guys, check me out, follow me on Twitter.
If you guys want to know whenever I'm going to do a little
gorilla stream on the YouTubes.
And you guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check.
blood flowing and if you oh yeah definitely all that blood
flow oh yeah wait before i go before i go oh yeah but if you
stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it uh i forgot
to talk about this but apparently there's this new website
uh there's this new website where um you can like pretend to
be ai or you prompt ai and it's just people like
role-playing as ai and stuff so i was just like oh i want to
check this website out is i don't remember what it's called
it's like what's it called ai uh i don't remember what it's
called but it's like on viral right now on twitter so i
checked the website on that's why it was really funny
because i was like i want to try it out and i was being a
little cringe i just wanted to see what the ai guy was gonna
say and then i literally wrote
oh yeah your ai slops i was the one that wrote one rv tubers
by the way i just i was like i wonder what this random what
this random person will say i'm like i'm trying to lose here
i say this i played manari
anyway guys i'm gonna call it here guys um i hope all of you
guys um have a good rest of the day and i'll see you guys
next time whenever i stream on my vacation um and i'm gonna
miss you guys of course i will miss stream i always miss
streaming and miss hanging out with you guys so uh stay
strong dragons i'll be back i promise stay strong i'll be
back guys and i'll see you guys later everyone bye everybody
bye